[Musique]
bonjour et bien moi c'est régis j'ai 29
ans je suis technicien en audiovisuel
j'aime bien un petit peu comme tout le
monde j'aime bien les vacances j'aime
bien la mer la détente les sorties bien
entendu mais particulièrement je
voudrais quelqu'un d'autre à
décontracter qu'ils soient pas
sophistiquée qui hors de l'hypocrisie et
là sont des points très importants pour
moi
en dehors de ça la profession pour moi
ça n'a pas grande importance à partir du
moment où cette personne aura une
certaine de créativité en dehors de ça
mais là je vous écrirai certainement pas
parce que j'ai une graphologique est
très très mauvaise et on va toujours
jugé un petit peu là dessus sinon je
suis en bonne santé
bonsoir je m'appelle françoise je suis
c'est qu'on peut appeler en terme
marketing une femme superbe corps et
l'esprit paraît-il clash à l'impunité et
caetera et ma recherche c'est celle de
d'une étincelle avec un homme entre 40
et 50 ans benda bon niveau et de très
bon standing
lorsque je dis ça ça s'attache plus à un
phénomène l'éducation et de comportement
que le site social
je m'appelle jean claude j'ai 30 ans je
suis célibataire je mesure 1 m 73
je suis lectrices yara nautique il
paraît que je suis enthousiaste
pondéreux pondéré généreux sentimentale
j'aspire à trouver une épouse qui soit
charmante brune mince royal affectueuse
délicate pour une union union réussie
avec un enfant il est évident qu'à notre
époque la situation
la vie facile à sécurité sont peut-être
les premières choses tu ne fais un bar
chercher je le comprends fort bien mais
que deviennent les gens comme moi qui
ont une situation modeste qui de
surcroît sont peut-être illettrés pas
assez cultivé et qui ont des loisirs
assez simple bien que je sois gentil
prévenant conciliant est prêt à faire
des concessions
je n'intéresse pas les personnes dites
intelligentes et qui sont d'un milieu
social différent du mien et j'en suis
fort triste je m'appelle chantal j'ai 24
ans
j'essaie lui la terre j'ai deux enfants
âgés de 4 ans et 2 ans je suis tout seul
depuis deux ans je pense que si je passe
mon annonce c'est que pour moi je pense
que ce serait plus facile de trouver un
homme dans la vie actuelle
ce que je voudrais c'est un homme qui
puisse me comprendre qu'ils puissent
m'accepter moi mes deux petits garçons
qui puisse nous aimer c'est bien le cas
moi qui soit gentil affectueux qui a du
caractère qui sait ce qu'il veut -
échange je veux rien la seule chose que
je voudrais c'est d'être aimé par lui le
soir quand j'ai le cafard
j'écris des poèmes un mari ou de chanter
après je pleure bonjour je m'appelle
emmanuel je suis célibataire
j'ai 31 ans je mesure 1 m 68 pour 60 kg
j'ai les cheveux châtains et les yeux
bleus et je porte des lunettes
je travaille actuellement dans une
maison d'édition de caractère je suis
très doux très sensible aussi très
sensuel mais je suis aussi assez timide
est assez réservé mes goûts j'aime le
sport la lecture mes auteurs préférés
sont kafka et graham greene
j'aime la musique classique mes auteurs
préférés sont poulenc debussy et ravel
mais j'aime aussi la musique pop tels
que les groupes anglais comme les
beatles et les rolling stones
j'aime aussi les bons restaurants et les
voyages je recherche une femme ou une
jeune femme pour faire une longue route
ensemble
en un mot pour faire ma vie avec elle
physiquement jusqu'à très calé les
cheveux longs bruns ou châtains qu'elle
ne soit pas trop grande je souhaiterais
en plus qu'elles soient assez ronde ou
même très ronde
corpulente outre est corpulente ou alors
qu'elle est une très forte poitrine
en ce qui concerne son caractère je
souhaite qu'elle soit très simple plutôt
bavarde car ce n'est pas mon cas
équilibré qu'elle est bon caractère et
qu'elle ait les mêmes goûts que moi en
ce qui concerne son âge sa situation où
sa race cela met un différend bonjour
j'ai 28 ans je me prénomme pierre j'ai
mis une annonce dans une agence
matrimoniale pour rencontrer une jeune
fille de mon âge ou à quelque chose près
qui arrive à me pour essayer de
comprendre aussi et les relations que je
pourrais avoir avec tantôt n'est que je
mets n'annoncez pas rencontré une fille
elle y est c'est la rentrée des jeunes
filles ou jeunes femmes qui soit assez
d'un côté libéré d'un autre côté qui
arrive à amay pouvoir m'écouter pendant
un temps et que je puisse
essayer de revoir cette personne ou d'un
certain temps des fois j'ai du mal à
exprimer comme ça la première fois et si
on essaye de se revoir peut toujours
essayer de marcher dans la suite
je m'appelle laurent j'ai 29 ans je suis
célibataire et j'aime le cinéma
alors bien sûr je recherche une jeune
femme 80 27 ans ou 30 ans peu importe
mais qu'ils soient effectivement un peu
sensible qui aime beaucoup le cinéma est
peut-être qu'il puisse savoir ce que
veut dire rosebud dans this is in game
et si cette personne c'est ce que veut
dire aux bugs ainsi yann gagne peut-être
qu'elle comprendra ce que ce que je
recherche
je me prénomme daniel g et 41 ans
je suis infirmière j'aime me les
contacts humains
j'ai été mariée pendant 13 ans je me
suis ennuyé pendant 13 ans
cela fait huit ans je suis divorcée et
je m'ennuie alors je cherche une
personne entre 40 et 50 ans avec lequel
je serai bien sensible assez cultivé qui
seraient susceptibles de me sortir de
mon ennui et qu'ils ne s'ennuient pas
non plus avec moi
[Musique]